Film Courage: You had something happen to
you which is a screenwriter’s worst nightmare
where a script of your’s was stolen?
Rachel K. Ofori, Producer/Writer:Yes, I
had a script stolen. I have two scenarios
that you can say the world stolen. But the
one that I think affected me deeply was I
trusted people that wanted me to write and
I was 19. This was my first hire for film,
a film script that I am being hired to write.
I worked with people that I really trusted
and they didn’t do the wrong thing but they
didn’t protect me to make sure the wrong
thing didn’t happen or even ask me questions
to make sure I was thinking of it.The film
originally they told me Well this is not really
where we want to go. We will circle back maybe
a year from now because we are going to go
with another idea. I said Okay, no problem.
I enjoyed the experience. I got to write a
film script start-to-finish and just kind
of waited.Then I saw the film. It was maybe
two or three years later and it was a little
different but it was like “Okay? I wrote
that line!” You know, one of those moments.
So I think it was a horrible experience but
I can’t say I’m glad it happened but a
lot of goodness came out of it. It caused
me to be so much more prudent and so much
more watchful and wise which is great for
personal use but also being someone on the
other end now, hiring writers and so forth
and even something I am working on right now
in pre-production, I want to educate every
young writer because it’s something that
no one is going to…I can’t say no one…but
there aren’t many people that are not going
to want to use you for your gift and that’s
a good thing.But you’ve got to be sure
that they use you in a way that you are comfortable
with being used. So its’ like it’s fine,
your gifts are here to be used and shown so
don’t feel like Oh, they are using me! That’s
fine, just put limits and boundaries in that
and that comes in with legal. So most of these
young writers…most of them unless they got
into a place where they shot up to the top
or they can have an agent or a lawyer and
this and that (somebody watching out for them)
they have no clue what paperwork needs to
be put in place and how that paperwork needs
to be worded to where they’re protected
and because of what I went through I researched
that and I didn’t just research it like
“Now I know,” but I also always bounced
it off of a lawyer. Even when I am giving
advice. I’m like “Hey this guy is in this
and does this clause mean this?” Because
that is what I am thinking, so just being
very watchful of it and also I am super protective
of writers. Like Argg! It’s like a Mama
Bear thing that comes out and a project that
I’m working on right now the writer called
me just a couple of days ago and “I just
want to thank you. You have been there every
step of the way. You weren’t even on the
project yet.” This is like way before pre-production,
just conversations. And he was like I just
felt so safe and I couldn’t have had a better
compliment than that. That a writer who was
around me felt safe because I experienced
the other way around.I want to make sure
that anyone around my presence, writers, producers
(whatever it is) they feel safe and they feel
that they can trust (like I did) but also
get the outcome that their trust actually
mattered and it was the right person to trust.
I never want to hurt that in someone. That
is something that I’m very mindful of and
I don’t think there’s an opportunity for
us to make bad decisions that every person
has that like maybe greed or whatever the
thing is that you see great people fall. When
you’ve already experienced what great people
do (what they can do in power) but you’ve
been on the other end of that, when you get
some power, you are going to be more mindful
of how you treat people.So I can say that
experience of having a script stolen, makes
me a better leader, makes me a better producer,
makes me a better writer, makes me a better
person because I know these people weren’t
bad people but they saw an opportunity and
they are like “Well we don’t have to really
pay her anymore. We don’t have to bring
her in. She is not owed any points. Let’s
just go, don’t even tell her.” That can
happen when you have greed. So I don’t look
or think of them as horrible people, I think
of them as people who succumbed to greed or
because they could. We all want a sense of
power and they used it in the wrong way. So
it helps me use it in the right way more often
and with more intention.Film Courage: What
are some tips…aside from having legal look
over a contract or even emails…what are
some signs (like a red flag) that a writer
should be aware of?Rachel: Red flags for young
writers or anyone is people asking you for
things that 1) You don’t understand or 2).
You didn’t agree with already. So it’s
like usually how it happens is they kind of
sneak it in there. It’s like Okay we have
an agreement and then it’s like “Hey can
you also do such-and-such.” And young writers
especially they are like “I can’t wait
to do these things.” So they just do it.
Don’t do it. Be okay or you can start writing
it, start working with it, but don’t tell
them. Don’t say okay. Don’t say absolutely.
Just say “Oh sure. Just have whoever call
me so we can change the contract.” You can
do it in such a way that you don’t seem
like you’re checking them. Just make it
seem like you’re just being helpful “I’ll
take care of it. I can talk to whoever, just
let me know. Do I need to sign something else?”
Ask an innocent question like that and I’ll
tell you those people will adjust their movements.
Just say “Oh great sure. Do I need to sign
something different?” If they say “No.”
That will be the next red flag that it’s
not only that they were maybe negligent, they
were probably trying to take advantage of
you. Because you do have to sign something.
There needs to be an adjustment and if they’re
not willing to do that you don’t need to
be in the situation.Or stay in the situation
because you know we have to be in places sometimes
where Okay, be amongst the snakes but like
the Bible says be a dove. We don’t need
to act like a snake so we need to know how
the snakes move. Be there and just keep very
watch and care on what you are doing and presenting
to them.So you are like “Hey, where is
that such and such?” “Oh yeah, I have
it pretty much ready, I just need whatever
paper I need to sign.” Bring it up later.
You don’t have to fight them or argue with
them.I see another thing young writers do
where “I read that such-and-such” or “my
friend said such-and-such.” And it’s like
now you’re just going to come off as a jerk
and that person might have been innocent in
this situation. So just come from an inquisitive
place and then record that response. I’m
not saying record that scenario or have a
phone recorder of whatever but after they
responded, write it down so you can then think
about it later and then talk about it with
a friend. Of course it’s great to talk it
over with someone in the industry but just
hearing yourself out loud talk to someone
helps. You kind of understand where someone
is moving, so write it down exactly how they
said. Send a text to yourself. I do Notes
all day with phone calls even when I am sitting
on a call, I am writing down certain moments
in the call just to kind of be “What just
happened here?”Just be mindful of requests
and seeing (not responding) but seeing how
they respond to you pushing back on their
requests in any capacity and that will be
a telltale sign that this is probably going
to be a situation where people are not going
to protect you. So you can stay in it but
be ready to protect yourself or bring someone
else in to protect you.Film Courage: I like
that! Let’s take the scenario where the
person tries to turn it around on you and
make it seem like you’re the one that’s
the problem. So let’s say they say “Well
I only operate with a handshake and I go on
good faith like that. And I would hope you
would trust me?” And that makes you feel
like “Oh, wow. Now this makes me look mistrustful.”
So you would almost want to prove to them
“Okay, yes that’s fine, we’ll do that.”
How do you deal with when they try to turn
it around (as has happened to a lot of people)
and make it seem like it doesn’t need to
be changed or initialed or noted?Rachel: I
think first understand that your trust has
to be rooted in truth. So trust is built.
You don’t owe anyone it, just have that
stance. I don’t owe trust to anyone. They
have to build it and I have to build it for
them. They don’t have to trust me to write
and go do my job. Don’t act like “I’m
a writer. I’ve done such-and-such.” Either
way you have to come with humility. But trust
has to be earned. Now you don’t have to
tell them that but you have to have that stance.
So let’s say someone says something like
that where it’s “Well I operate on a handshake
and I hope you trust me.” “Absolutely,
I hope so too. So I’m going to start writing
on this and just whenever you’re ready you
can give me a piece of paper and you’re
going to put this in writing and then I can
deliver it.” It’s just for me and there
are so many people out here that you can’t
trust, right?” Like kind of connect with
them… “Right?” And then they are like…what
crazy person wouldn’t be like “No, trust
everyone.” Give them truth and if your trust
is rooted in truth and you stay in a place
of truth, you won’t come off as combative
or difficult. Just stay in a place of truth.
“There are so many people out here, right?”
“Yeah, I get it.” “So yeah for me I’m
going to start moving (sure) but I just can’t
deliver anything until that piece of paper
only because I’ve seen so many crazy things
happen…And I don’t think that would be
you? I have to put those things in there to
alleviate something that could end up being
conflict.” But still trust has to be earned,
so let them earn it. And also have that same
stance on you. If you’re not making deadlines,
if you’re not giving them proofs of things
and giving them the types of examples that
they wanted, providing them with enough people
that they can call and say “Yeah, you’re
great.” Whatever the case may be, don’t
be offended when they are not trusting for
you either. So you have to trust. You are
not owed it and you don’t owe it to anyone
but still I operate in the space of for building
it I am going to try and confront them with
truth not in confrontation in a negative way.
So I would say that is the way to deal with
it. Just kind of respond very graciously but
also then bring them the truth and they can’t
disagree with you which is “A lot of crazy
things happen here, right?” And then go
from there.